I was high the other day walking around
New York and I saw a blind guy it's
being walked into traffic by seeing eye
dog so I stepped in I was like whoa
buddy can I give you a hand he goes I
don't need your charity a piece of
I was like Hey blind guy
I'm over here
also can you really afford to be a prick
and you're pretty vulnerable I could
just nut check you you never see it
coming right
so I was fascinated with this mean blind
guy and I'm watching with a seeing eye
dog and I thought you know what who
picks up his
blind guy's not doing it this might be
the best life hack of all time I'm gonna
steal that
next time I walk my dog I'm not bringing
some plastic bags I'm bringing some
sunglasses and a wiggly stick okay
my dog takes a crap some guys like
excuse me sir I'm like I've never seen a
sunset
must be nice